and LeBron it's your 21st season but
again you're showing no signs of slowing
down you were driving like a freight
train in Fr uh to KD does playing
against him kind of bring you back and
make it feel like no time Miss pass yeah
uh absolutely I mean uh I never take for
granted the opportunities and the the
games that we get an opportunity to be
on the same floor at the same time OB
we've had so many battles but you know
over his career and my career we just
been able to make so many plays um
individually um far respect excuse me
far respective teams throughout that and
you know being able to you know be in
two Olympics with him as well um you
know I think that's um you know pretty
spe one Olympic I'm sorry in 12 um you
know and just I mean just we don't have
many matchups left um not sure how many
we have left but so you don't never want
to take you know take it for granted
when you're out there with with such a a
great player one of the you know the
best I ever played this game so you it's
always it's always a treat and um it's
fun last two
Rachel following up on that what do you
remember about when you first played him
the first time I know you met him even
before
that what do you remember from back then
uh I'll be honest I do not remember um
and I remember a lot um remember
everything I do but that's one I don't
remember the first time I played uh KD
but um was he in he was in Seattle yeah
he was in Seattle I think it was in
Cleveland if I'm not mistaken now my my
mind is starting to remember yeah I do
I'm starting to remember it now um I'm
starting to remember it now um I tell
you one thing he's a lot stronger now um
you know and um you know a lot of people
always talk about you know his weight or
whatever the case may be KD is he will
get you up off him for sure you know out
on the floor so he's put in a lot of
work but he's just always been he's just
a natural born score you know you have
certain guys just come into this lead
that's just that's what they do and
there's nothing you can do about it um
Carmelo Anthony was one of those guys um
Alan Iverson is one of those guys Kevin
Durant's one of those guys it's just and
listen you just hope that they miss you
know you just play great defense and
maybe you can you know get a couple
turnovers on them make it a little tough
on them but I mean we we felt like we
made it as tough as it could be had 39
tonight so um but this is like I said
it's a treat to uh to be out there with
KD Trey five for sure last question